I am open to everything now I'm open to
things that I never thought I would have
been open to and I I really think that
the door fully th came open I I I've
realized that everything in the in the
news is BS everything there there is
nothing that I can consume on any Legacy
Media that I can trust and that is
shocking and that's disturbing and it
makes you wonder how long it's been
going on for and I'm concerned it might
have been a very a long time
yeah all right Drew you get no intro
how's that for an intro you were past
intro you've been doing this for a long
time man I it's it's got to the point
where what I'm like share or is just
somebody with with a single name one
syllable name except it's Dr Drew I call
I call you drew as a friend but you are
Dr and by the way David I I am so
excited to be here I don't even know
where to start with you I I'm not
kidding I I I I you've been calling us
your Clarion call to return to Florida
mve to Florida has been ringing in my
ears for quite some time every time we
come to South Florida we are happier
people are happy everything's
functioning business is work what my
wife sitting over here I was telling her
the other night we walked around Coconut
Grove I was like I just feel so good
seeing people thriving and socializing
and happy and I just miss that there's
not many places in the country where
that exists anymore and yet you live in
a place called Los Angeles tell me about
that place it's interesting place we
became friends there I said I'm leaving
you you said I should leave and and yet
you have not left you're here look at
you you're glowing you're glowing
actually I got a sunburn your great
Miami Heat here that's what most of that
is I was out in the sun yesterday but uh
California sucks it's very depressing we
have you know Susan my wife's from
Orange County and so we spend a bunch of
time out there and that's a little bit
of an enclave from what does suck in in
California and uh and we are Deep Roots
you know my practices there everything
is there it's kids are there it's hard
to pull yourself out though I fantasize
about it all the time so I've been gone
for about two and a half years now and
you were considering at least for a
still we talk about it all time no no no
not considering moving I I accept that
it's very clear to me you were
considering running for governor oh yeah
there were some discussions about that
yeah um obviously the recall didn't work
out now looks like new may be on his way
to replacing old Joe I mean is has
anything gotten bad there is or anything
gotten better there is there any sense
of hope there is there anything it's
easy for me to do all the negative stuff
everyone gets it it there is you know
the the main thing that has been my sort
of what's making me so deeply Disturbed
what started my my my problem in
California was the way they dealt with
the homeless because these are people
that I these are my patients when people
get sever severe enough mental illness
severe enough addiction that they end up
on the street that is the most seriously
deteriorated and they die they die and
on the streets of LA county and they die
at 7 to eight per day and my opinion
that is negligent homicide period and
it's been that for eight years and it
just hasn't changed it's it's so clear
what to do it's easy it's not a problem
San Francisco did it they moved them out
in one day and they could have gone hey
come with me we've got a place for you
and created a a therapeutic living
environment with you know Steps step
them through it to get vocational rehab
return them to a meaningful life can
treat these things wait just not to
confuse people they got them out because
the Chinese uh prime minister was coming
but they're all back you know that they
where they put them or what they did
with them but they cleared them out so
it is possible to go hey come with me
that's all you do go hey come with me we
the we have privileged brain disorders
where Insight is the main problem you
people with severe mental illness have
something called anosognosia they block
the insight to what's happening to them
and and they will die they just that is
a terminal illness worse than most
cancers for the setting of addiction and
they just no big deal but there is hope
they they're looking at improving
conservatorship they're starting to talk
about it as a as a mental health thing
and an addiction problem and they're
trying to say that we've got to get
these people treatment it would be I
know exactly how to structure the
programs I know exactly how to staff it
I know exactly where to put it I have we
pick the building and we could put
thousands of people through these
programs so easily but but do you think
they can actually do it I mean I always
used to find it kind of funny maybe you
wouldn't find this funny as but I always
found it kind of funny driving around La
there would be signs Billboards all over
the place for La mental health blah blah
and I always thought well that would be
the worst place to get your mental
health fixed in some LA City Hospital
like to me that would be crazy I suspect
you'd be up to something different but
do you think that the people there the
Machinery there has the will to do
anything that would actually work no it
have to be re it have to be redone
apprciate the honesty and there would
have to be laws in place that or undoing
of laws that allow you to help these
people and but it wouldn't be that hard
I mean what you're pointing at is that
janere LA County Health Facilities have
trouble functioning right and they
historically they certainly do and
certainly on the mental health side but
a lot of that problem is the laws you
can't keep them you can't put them in
you can't do anything with them unless
they say I'm here and I want help and
they continue to say that and otherwise
you can't do anything and nobody with
addiction says that here's what people
with addiction are concerned with you
know what they're concerned with getting
more drugs doing drugs that's what
they're concern that's the nature of the
illness in all the years that you've
been this do you see the the actual
because of the um the potency of the
drugs do you see it all getting much
worse now like in a different way or or
is that when people are at that level
already is it kind of the same but now
it's more it's more D it's more easily
addictive so because the more potent the
drug the higher the the delivery system
if you're using your lungs if you're
using intravenous that increases the
addictive quality and of course the
potency as well but really the main
thing with the fentanyls you're talking
about synthetic opiates which is the
danger there's just such a narrow window
to death and so they're dying at an
incredible rate and they're mixing I
know someone that died about three week
it's very common it's look
it's this is what drives me insane
because that if you're shooting Ivy
opiate or heroin or fentanyl and you're
on the street you are going to die that
is a that is the nature of the condition
it's just a matter of when it's a it's a
progressive this is the part that all
the California legislature leaves out is
a Progressive illness that ends in death
and if you and it's treatable right
that's the horrible thing it's it has a
worse prognosis than the vast majority
of cancers untreated by far and it's
treatable how much of this do you now
connect to your politics because
obviously yeah well because I don't
think of you as political first but now
especially in light of covid I think
you've become more political as I said
you were thinking about running for
governor you're in a place that
everything's kind of backwards yes but I
sort of think of you as just an old
school liberal who's now been hit with
the frying pan which is how many of us
are I I I I really think if we had
talked to each other 12 years ago we
would have been exactly in the same
place we old school liberal started
moving towards libertarian then I met
some Libertarians and I thought well I'm
not that because I you believe in
driver's license okay it's funny Leo
trell is the one that really pointed
that out to me he goes I was he we were
doing we were co-hosting a radio show
together and I was like I'm libertarian
I don't want leave me alone leave me
alone and and he goes what do you want
to do with the homeless he goes I want
the government to fix he goes oh okay Mr
libertarian you with the government to
fix the homeless thing a class liberal
is just a guilty libertarian that it
could be I I'm in that zone yeah uh oh
but people keep calling me I don't know
where I I I I just I want I personally
want to be left alone but I do want
government to function and solve some of
the problems we have so to get us to
where we started so now you come to the
free state of Florida I know personally
what that difference is oh my gosh what
what keeps all you said that your you
said de roots and
but like do you have do you think that
there's enough good people there to turn
any of this around I don't mean just
that they can maybe get one good drug
hospital or this or that so that was oh
gosh that was what I was thinking when I
started thinking about F first I
thought well damn shiff is my
congressman he doesn't do anything for
us and he was running was running again
at the time and I thought I should I
should run for that that position
because somebody's got to do something I
kept think saying we have to do
something cuz people are not doing
anything for us somebody's got to do
something so I kind of thought about
that and then no and then somebody came
around oh you should run for governor so
they actually put me on the phone with
Schwarzenegger who encouraged me I
thought he would talk me out of it he
encouraged me say the greatest thing you
could ever
do I'm not going to quote what he said
but he said you you got to be prepared
for the the politicians up there which
is the hard part yeah um and then I I
had prostate cancer I needed some
radiation therapy that summer so I said
all right that's that's enough God's
telling me something I'll just get the
radiation and and Not only was God
telling me something my wife Susan said
no don't do this I don't want to do this
yeah uh and so we've sort of stepped out
of it since then I should continued to
say no but I still have this feeling
that somebody's got to do something and
so what we've been doing um my something
lately is this um streaming show we've
been doing I think we really became more
sort of uh popular and entrenched since
I was last year we do it Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday at 3:00 Pacific it's
called Dr Drew we've been interviewing
uh all so many of the Physicians and
researchers that were cancelled during
covid and my original sort of notion
with that was well these are incred
they're decorated professionals I mean
why did they cancel these guys so I
already had a curiosity like what what
what what's going on here and I thought
well very minimum maybe I'll learn
something which I did from every single
one and sometimes a lot do you miss
anything now that you're doing the
online thing about the mainstream thing
cuz you had many many how many shows
have you had on mainstream Med over the
years probably a dozen or something I
mean it's it's aot oh yeah about yeah I
think the first television show I ever
did was your HLN show I think that was
literally the first TV is that right
that's fantastic yeah and I always
thought it was funny because you had a
great Studio but sometimes they would
keep us all in different boxes different
rooms right so you'd be in there I'd be
like wait I want to be in the room with
this guy and they'd have five other
guests and we'd all be in rooms next to
each other but it seemed like we were
all in different countries so
we
we sort of invented the boxes looking
out to camera we like five people in
boxes that the CNN that took but people
didn't understand we were literally in
the same hallway so what what happened
was they were like we had to you know be
creative redo your show and Bert du bro
was my my at my EP and we both went well
audience if we had an audience that
would make a difference so if you
remember they built an audience yeah
yeah I think I did it once actually in
studio with with an audience and we
bring a couple of co-hosts in and we do
an audience thing with it was really
good they they didn't want to pay for
the audience and so we started coming
back into the studio just a dark room
and that looked weird and so then we
just went back to the boxes and so so do
you miss anything about that or now
you're you own your thing you're doing
locals you're we're doing the same thing
we're on Rumble like Rumble we doing
extremely well thank you for that I mean
it's happy to help I this whole world of
parallel economy come to Florida and
then I'll have given you my entire
collection of stuff your entire life
yeah but well I want to give you South
Park I talk about that before we're done
because oh my guys will be very happy
I'm enjoying that more than anything I
can't believe you've not been a South
bar Watcher all these years but that
let's make sure we don't leave that out
okay
um I I do television is a medium of hits
and when you do get involved with a hit
there's there's almost nothing more
powerful than that it does reach a lot
of people and in terms of doing
something that makes a difference I I
still miss that trying to get a large
audience and move them and change them
and you know affect them in certain ways
but you are doing that with the show but
I I get it you mean in like some weird
cultural way where we all have to talk
about the view as opposed to them
talking about yeah we you know we're yes
and maybe this I I have a suspicion that
Rumble and you know all these other
platforms might get there you end you're
you know you're ending up doing
essentially a broadcast because you're
on so many different platforms talking
to so many different people what I do
like about this that's different from
that is you have such highly motivated
audiences they they appreciate it
they're tired of people disdaining them
or selling them things when they feel
like the the whoever the company is
that's selling them something actually
hates them that's how they feel that's
terrible that's awful how how much we've
talked about this a little bit before
but how much did your political
Evolution shift because of the covid
craziness because when I had you on last
time in studio was still in La so it's
about over two and a half years ago you
were still sort of saying some nice
things about fouchy and I know you guys
have a history I sense you've shifted a
bit on that or at least you're amable to
some other ideas I am I am open to
everything now I'm open to things that I
never thought I would have been open to
and I I really think that the door fully
th came open I I I've realize that
everything in the in the news is BS
everything there there is nothing that I
can consume on any Legacy Media that I
can trust and that is shocking and
that's disturbing and it makes you
wonder how long it's been going on for
and I'm concerned it might have been a
very long time yeah was there a straw
that broke the camels back on that
specifically yes I was going to tell you
that my my interview with RF my first
interview with RFK Jr he was so
reasonable and so smart and so many
interesting ideas and enlighten me to
this cozy relationship between the
regulators and the Pharma companies
which I really wasn't aware of I mean I
can't let a Pharma company
representative into my office to give me
a pen with a drug name name on it and
yet those guys are living together and
cross-pollinating J I mean that's
mindboggling to me so and that he had a
very sensible didn't necessarily fully
agree with it but a sensible idea about
vaccine research that he would like to
push forward not that vaccines are bad
his family's all vaccinated my family's
all vaccinated and at the end of that
interview he said something to me I've
met him now many times since then he
goes oh my good you know Drew you are so
courageous to talk to me and I and I
thought it blew me back in my chair I
thought
I need courage to have a conversation
with an adult in a public setting and he
was right this this is a time where I
didn't realize how much speech was being
suppressed uh how much was being
manipulated how much then what happened
after that was the Twitter files and
they started seeing what was going on
and it just it's just been to me this is
all
reprehensible and what has happened as a
result I don't think I've shifted my
political views I've just just really in
the I never imagined I'd be this point
in my life at this age and place in my
career freedom and freedom fighting and
the courage to stand up for it have been
the most important thing in my life
right now and that's crazy that is CRA I
live in the United States of America and
I have to worry about freedoms I'm to
fight for Freedom that is an insanity
and I'm hoping it's something that will
pass soon yeah well you know there's a
far less chance they're going to put you
in a goog in the Free State of Florida
rather than the Comm come to Florida
come to flor of California all right
I've sold florid what do you think
psychologically this is one of the
things I talk about on the show a lot
that that basically psychologically now
if you are somebody that watches
corporate press and pretty much think
that is true and then you're someone
that maybe watches this or Rogan or you
or just that mix of people RFK in there
too of course that your worlds are so
different now that psychologically as a
nation how do we put that together like
you could literally be basically living
in a completely different world than
your neighbor we that is what we are
doing that's what's happening right now
now and it it's actually makes me sad
because it prevents any kind of
discourse and conversation people get I
can feel their stomach muscles
tightening up when I just try to have a
conversation and that's that's so
disturbing to me I I I guess I think
what's going to
happen I think
enough uh sort of slowly uncovering of
how much distortions have gone on and
how arbitrary and capricious and and and
dangerous and horrible consequences
these decisions have had it's going to
come to light I don't know if it's going
to be that they're really are excess
deaths I'm worried that there are if
there are that's going to keep happening
and we're going to see something I don't
know if it's co I don't know if it's co
plus vaccine but these conversations
will evolve with time and eventually I
think people will start to go oh I'm
starting to see a bigger picture I think
the I think the a turning point was when
foui admitted the six foot distance was
invented out of whole cloth it was
invented for and and I knew that two
years ago by talking to all these
canceled doctors and I talked to a guy
named Paul Alexander two years ago who
was in the room when uh Redfield is that
was name made the decision he goes why
why 6 feet there's an aerosolized virus
it' be 30 to 60 feet certainly 10 feet
and they actually agreed on maybe 10
feet they took 10t to the off the White
House and some political operative said
well no one will ever agree to that just
say 6 feet for and so it was never a
medical decision it was no scientific
basis to it whatsoever it's had no
utility and yet I mean think about this
St the whole world adopted it the entire
world that to me is the really
astonishing part about that experience
of covid that lockdown was adopted by
the world six feet was adopted by the
world masks were adopted by the world
with none of it being considered for
risk reward analysis like what might
Happ happen as a result of this and it
was obvious to me there was going to be
horrible mental health consequence it
was obvious I want to get to that
obvious uh or is there any medical data
to support this you were crushed if you
tried to have that conversation that's
going to start to come to light for
people do you think there will ever be
any Reckoning whatsoever I mean
basically everyone who got us into this
either still has their job or have
retired with with cushy retirements or
Andor made hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars in stocks on these
things I mean is there any Reckoning
anywhere I hope at at minimum
particularly young people become Furious
they should be outraged and angry at
what was done to them if that happens I
will think personally I think that's
enough now I know there's a lot of
people that want retribution all kinds
of legal action whether civil or
criminal I I really worry about that I I
I'm telling you uh the present moment I
become obsessed with revolutionary
France obsessed and I wanted to put a
chapter in my book on narcissism on
pre-revolutionary France because it was
the only period of history that I could
find which as with as much narcissism
and childhood trauma and one of my one
of my conclusions that I wanted to put
in that chapter which my editor told me
was too speculative was that there would
be scapegoating there would be
Guillotines that's what Guillotines is
just scap just massive scapegoating and
never heard of cancellation but here it
came so scapegoating became this social
media phenomenon that I
predicted um why did I bring this up um
so the the problem is that if you if you
pull people up on the guillotine The
Guillotines just kept keep going and
eventually everybody go it's a
mathematical certainty of scapegoating
eventually everybody first it was a
jacoban then it was a sankula and then
it was the royalist everybody goes on
the guillotine if somebody doesn't say
stop so so what at the all right so if
that's not possible or not realistic or
you're sort of afraid of what the end
part is you'll never get to the truth
right because people will be so
defensive and scared they're not going
to come forward with what actually
happened I'm I want the truth out that's
the most important thing so would the
bigger problem then be that the
pharmaceutical companies seemingly have
done none of that internal research or
investigation or anything right like as
far as I can tell they're still into all
of this and wef is talking about disease
X and the rest of it like that it all
just kind of come around again well
that's the great that's the great risk
right I I don't think people will put up
for it I think that there's enough
outrage I think they will oh my God that
I I if I think they would just say no
this is the real one we we did screw up
on Co and a lot of it was wrong but this
one it's 10 times worse and they're
going to show you a video from China
some guy wigging out on the floor and I
think people would do it
again I'm actually not in certain places
I'm actually more concerned that they do
need to social distance in some
meaningful way and we don't because we
don't believe them I I think that's
possible yeah I I think that's a higher
probability and probably better you know
I I before Co hit right when it was
hitting I did an interview with a guy
named Larry brilliant he's the world's
leading expert on small poox and he said
you don't you don't need to do anything
when acade when epidemics hit people
naturally isolate they they watch out
for themselves and they isolate socially
that's just a natural phenomenon and it
is inevitable so the idea of having all
the centralization and Authority on high
is the problem right now it is it is
making things worse what do you make of
the the psychological component now for
young people because we're seeing rates
of anxiety that are through the roofed
now drug use all the I mean I think you
can actually connect this to the gender
confusion too like just everything is
kind of up in the air at this point for
these people I just I kept saying during
the lockdowns that you were destroying 8
to 15 year olds you're destroying them
this is the age in which the peer
relationship is so important and you're
not allowing them that you're handing
them iPads and where they're getting
sexting and watching porn anywhere
they're not getting any education and
you're telling them they can't contact
their peers and if they do they're going
to kill their
family and in the meantime shelter in
place remember Garcetti kept saying
every night shelter in Place shelter in
place that is a phrase s reserved for an
incoming nuclear weapon I I I could
that's what that is or an active shooter
if to say you were at illegal parties at
my house Dr Drew I don't think it's
going to cost you your license at this
point you're right those were illegal
was was was the French underground back
in those days right we were like this
this like group trying to put
information out trying to continue to
share ideas and uh if you're 9 years old
and you're telling them that the shelter
in place and you're going to kill your
family and no peer contact of course
there's going to be depression anxiety
and developmental delays and cognitive
issues it's just inevitable and on top
of that there the the economy to the
young people that I've spoken to looks
bleak not only does the economy look ble
the the usual sorts of motivations for
engagement they can't get inspired by it
there are a lot of like who cares why do
I everything sucks we suck America sucks
you Boomer suck why do I want to
dedicate my time and live life to some
Pursuit what what am I going to do with
it it's really sad really it makes me
crazy that's why I said when I was going
around walking around Coconut Grove and
seeing a lot of young people out there
socializing I'm like please yes more
this so what what do you do I mean from
a therapist perspective what would you
do if you're you're talking to now a
group of 12y olds who okay they were
nine when this was happening they're
anxiety ridden they're confused about a
bunch of stuff like what what do you
actually do like anything you try to you
know manage the conditions whatever
comes along you try to get them to
engage in reality on reality's terms and
then make a difference how do you
because you know most people get through
crises of any type or even mental
illness of any type for that matter with
service of some type there's always that
some sort of Engagement as part of it
and you've got to get them there and my
I I would not be good with that
population because I would say aren't
you angry aren't you pissed aren't you
Furious you're not I'm not supposed you
don't do that in therapy you don't give
them your stuff but I hope they get to a
place where they are Furious livid and
want to make a difference and get things
back on track where people people can be
inspired there's also a spiritual mality
that's been going on in this country for
quite some time and that has become
acute I I don't know exactly what that
looks like to solve it but we we've got
to do something on that front where do
you think the prescription drug uh I
would say pandemic falls into that maybe
that's not you the
overb saw yeah I saw something uh I
think a week ago we showed it on the
show that about 10% of American adults
are on something 48hd you know either
adderal or one of these things and to me
it seems like even if a huge percentage
of those people it's necessary in some
respect in helping them yes that a a
society that 10% of its people are
drugged one way or another there's
something much bigger going on here I I
think that's true I there is something
bigger going on and in terms of the
medication I think we are this is what
always happens in mental health we are
are at once
overprescribing and underprescribing
people I me look at the streets yeah
people who need medication aren't
getting it and if they don't want to
take it you're supposed to just go okay
when they die because they don't and
then there are people that come in with
a little um ordinary misery when when uh
Sigman Freud first this I don't know if
this apocryphal story or not but Sigman
Freud apparently when he hit the hit the
shores in New York reporters came up and
said Freud what do you hope to achieve
here in America and he said well I hope
to understand the difference between
real mental illness and ordinary
misery and we have we have lost track of
for book ordinary misery it's a good you
can have it no it's fine you can have it
you can have it but but we need ordinary
misery it it's good for us it's how we
create resiliency and how we solve
problems and we are we are intolerant of
ordinary misery and at the same time
we've lost track of what it even means
to be happy and happiness has become
this what's called I think we've talked
about this before UD dionic happy excuse
me
hedonic happiness which is just woohoo
which is great I love that kind of
happiness but it it doesn't last and
it's always an appeti of drive to more
more more UD demonic happiness which is
an active engagement in a meaningful
nourishing life people don't even
understand what that is anymore so it's
basically sort of the difference between
a sense of purpose which would be the
latter and just like I'm having a great
time today because I'm going to the
amusement park a a good life and a party
and I when I first started thinking
about this different I thought oh yeah
my heroin addicts are super happy first
hit of the day is that are they happy is
that happiness but they're happy in that
moment but it's it's not happiness
happiness and you know I sort of lately
I've been people have been resonating
with this when I say
look Jesus Christ lived a purposeful
good life wasn't always happy if he had
focused on hedonic tone on that kind of
Happiness things would have turned out
quite differently and often a good life
is a life of sacrifice a life of
Engagement a life of of work of doing
hard work so how do you all right we
talked about how you can get people off
some of the drugs let's say how do you
get people off all of the wrong ideas
now when you also have a generation that
is confused about sexuality they're
confused about the founding of the
nation just that that freedom is bad and
good you up is down and two plus two is
five all those things that's a different
type of addiction different problem uh I
think reality has a way of asserting
itself I think reality I'm I'm watching
you know sort of my children's peer age
kind of wake up in the real world and
kind of go oh well maybe that isn't so
maybe that wasn't so true or maybe I was
a little deep in it ideology whenever
ideology takes hold humans suffer they
just
do uh I mean just look at history so we
need to really Hammer I mean there's so
much engagement in social media you can
talk about fre you Freedom you can bring
ideas out that they haven't heard before
you can constantly push his hisorical
sort of tidbits out so people come to
understand what what this country is
founded on and what the other histories
of other countries have been that we can
learn from that they seem totally
disconnected from and so it's it's um I
just think persistence I think keeping
it going and allowing reality to assert
itself and then I'm hoping a real anger
will emerge in young people where they
go hey I was I was taught some
and they I believed it and now it didn't
serve me well and I'm angry about it
it's funny the therapist who wants
people to be angry yeah yeah I'm I'm an
internist you got remember I'm an
internist by training so I go back to my
medical Roots even though I worked in a
psychiatric hospital for 35 years but
yes I want people to be furious but is
the I guess counter to that that the
Doom scrolling and the endless amount of
information it's nice to have the good
information out there but that thing
also and the filters on pictures and
nobody thinks they look right and all
the rest of it the screens are a problem
screens are no no doubt the screens are
part of of the distress that's going on
right now particularly for young people
so what do you do about that you know
the cat is out you to solve problem I
know the horse is out of the barn uh for
a lot of a lot of
generations and particularly sort of um
Millennial age they're you're not going
to take them away from screens and Jen Z
probably not either but you need to
there needs to be a consensus that of
limiting screen time for the younger
kids you've got to do it it's hard and
the only way it'll happen is if all
parents in every given community do it
together because otherwise it'll be
sharing screens during the day and stuff
right so yeah so okay so you have your
kids got it's going to be hard I've got
somebody for you they'll coach you up
yeah do you she's a psychologist that
just specializes in this area I can see
it now and everybody says oh well my
kids are never going to be on the
screens and it's like yes you might want
a nice quiet dinner at a restaurant one
night and you hand them the iPad and
then it's five years later and then
they're just whatever they do they're
making cookies on that thing I get it we
we have multiples you're in survival
mode when you have multiples we
absolutely would have thrown thrown our
kids on screen just to survive you know
about Miss Rachel you know Miss Rachel
Miss Rachel is like this huge YouTuber
and supposedly she's like the one you
know she's an early
educator she's the one yeah but it's
like it's not flashy and it's not fast
and it's not destroying so she's the one
so basically the only thing I watch now
is Miss Rachel I was put on Miss but we
don't even give even that we try to
limit it to just a few minutes just
before dinner so we can sit down for a
second but but I can see the challenge
and it's almost to me it strikes me as
just an unwinable there's just no win
cuz we all wish we were better with
these things even me a guy that takes a
month off in August and I try not to
tweet on weekends and all that stuff
nobody's perfect so no there's no
perfect parent we're screwed and your
kids will hate you for a little while
anyway want you do you know how it goes
but but it's okay they'll be good
they'll be they'll be good um but uh
yeah I was just thinking about South
Park again and one of the things we did
that maybe was inadvisable I watch South
Park with my sons particularly probably
from about sixth grade on and I I always
felt okay about it even though there was
some inappropriate stuff in there
because we discuss it all we talk about
and those guys what is your take I i'
I've been dying all day to talk to about
this so what you're what you're
referencing for people that haven't seen
is we've put out a couple of these
videos where I'm watching South Park for
the first time it was my guy's idea so
the reason so you must have missed that
the reason that we did it the first time
was because I was a Simpsons guys so
1989 The Simpsons came out okay and I I
Still loveed The Cosby Show that was
obviously before Bill had well I guess
he was having his adventures but but
there was this big there was this big
debate because they were both on at the
same time which one was gonna take over
and I loved Cosby and I loved the
Simpsons and then I went The Simpsons
route and then that was 89 and then
around 95 96 South Park came up but
Simpsons was you know season seven
season eight like Primo best years of
The Simpsons and I was just like I'm
only going to watch one cartoon that was
my POS and then Family Guy came in
around and then so yeah like later in
the last 10 years I've watched some
family guy that but I just basically was
just like no I'm a Simpsons guy and
that's it that's how I am with like Star
Wars Lord of the Rings I'm I like robots
you know the little Dwarfs with hairy
feet for other people this guy he loves
you can do so much so that's why so
that's why I never watch it but but of
course everyone's always saying to me
Dave you gota did you see this did you
see that so now we've started watching
them and I have to tell you these people
are ill
mentally they're ill but they have no no
it's so twisted deep weird and insane
and Brilliant but they have Crystal
brains they they can see the future they
it's amazing they never they're always
about three years ahead of the game in
in Extreme Ways where you think oh my
God this over the I remember I me did
you see uh you're you're still early in
the game well I'm all over the place
they just pick random one so uh
gentlemen get him the one where PC
principal is uh at the fraternity house
going down the hall with the yeah they
ex excited everybody instead like rug
use because when that happened I thought
I thought oh my God you know then I
thought oh and now it happened now it's
actually happening now people are doing
that well even I did watch one or they
showed me one when they were doing this
member Berry thing that like everything
is just like a retread of everything
before and that also sort of seems I
think sort of psychologically why we're
kind of screwed at the moment that we
can't as a society we don't create
anything new anymore we reboot Star Wars
we reskined you know a Marvel movie that
our dreams are now just becoming like
vestiges of an earlier more creative
time that's not healthy for a society
well but I I I don't I think it's a
combination of factors I mean I think
when things go negative there's a
natural Nostalgia why there would be
Nostalgia for the worst decade in
American history the 70s I cannot
imagine but there seems be a little 80s
come on 80s pretty 80s was lovely and it
was fun and that's that's the thing
that's missing now is fun right and the
80s were fun and so I'm seeing little
hints that maybe something like that is
is sort of emerging go ahead no well I
was just as you were saying that like it
seems to me also partly what's missing
is that we've so atomized sex now
because porn is now everywhere and it's
a private thing for people and it's like
we can joke about it but nobody talks
about it but like there's nothing sexy
anymore there's no there aren't sexy
movies there aren't sexy TV shows there
used to be magazines if you went to the
supermarket and you'd see like a sexy
person on a magazine you it would just
something that was there we've it's just
like sex is G men are women now we're
fat is is hot like something about that
also seems like it's really screwing
with people it is young people are not
having sex at least the majority of them
are not the way I mean we it used to be
fun we used to used to try to engage
with people you want you try to have sex
with people but now that goes as
problems with consent objectification
fetishization M it just it just gets a
lab or the app you just know every
freaking thing about that person first
you know all their likes and likes all
the food they like there's just no
mystery yeah and the other thing is
these are constructed identities too
online and it's the and the the skill of
going up to somebody there's a whole
empty set of the skill of dating and
meeting and getting to know people and
that's that's how the self emerges is
into an interpersonal context and we
need to practice lots of that to decide
who we are in a relationship what we
like in other people how we fit with
other people takes a lot of time and
energy to figure that out what do you
make of the porn part of this
specifically related to psychological
like stuff because I was you remember
the uh what was his name Jeffrey tubin
on CNN so he gets caught whacking off on
a zoom call yep and to me what was funny
about that not was that he was doing it
as much as like in between being on CNN
that's what he's doing like like but
that a lot of people are doing that yes
like that's like just there now
consuming and compulsive and it's it is
um it's been a grave concern of mine uh
from the addiction standpoint because
that's where we're seeing lots of that
we don't have any idea the full impact
on young people uh I will tell you what
I saw I've seen over the last 15 20
years is young
males feeling frightened they don't want
to be seen as objectifying women or
being ma toxic masculine so they pull
back they certainly wouldn't talk to
somebody who's has a beer in their hand
because that's you know they can't
consent then you know you were again
seen as a predator still happens a lot
where men are told that that's the case
they pull back they head off into the
porn and they sort of hide there like
okay I'm okay I got my porn and I and
they miss the de developmental
Milestones of dating and cons you know
learning to do those things and for the
first time I had a show that just ended
this year it's kind of a sort of a love
line esque show called Dr Drew after
dark over at your mom's house Tom sigur
and his wife Christina Peep and on that
show for the first time in my career of
talking to young people young males were
starting to talk about visiting
prostitutes this was becoming part of
the option to deal with the loneliness
and the disconnect and that's not good
that's going to be a real mess that's
probably just the next extension of the
only fans thing then they're just like
oh well you could also pay them for this
literally I mean or person maybe who
knows I mean somebody like who knows
what yeah it's all it all goes there and
then now I'm hearing from women going
where the men right what's going on here
I there no that's and so young women are
dating much older men and and these poor
guys in the middle here are just oh my
God it's just just that's that's
actually exactly what I wanted to ask
you next because I'm seeing a ton of
that I know a lot of girls like let's
say 25 to 40y old girls that are single
cool good-looking good job seemingly
together yeah and they cannot find guys
period and that that's a really weird
thing that's I didn't even think of the
well now they find older men thing they
do that but that's not good for family
building and no and there's no sense of
that or what even a family does I mean
why that is important in terms of the
foundational sort of units of culture
and and and a society and the most
appropriate healthy environment to raise
children to people committed to each
other Susan was saying that she thinks
also women also are sort of unrealistic
about what men are what how they work
and and because they're not doing the
kind of dating where you learn how men
what men are in these heterosexual
couples they they're just they're
they're unclear about what it would even
be like to be with a young male what do
you think we're you know we're kind of
animals is when we're young we're
animals period right I'm not I'm not a
doctor but we are primates but but I
mean you know it doesn't matter
orientation or gender gender identity
whatever XY males tend to be intense
when they're young when when did you
first see the kind of crazy explosion of
of the gender confusion like obviously
in practice and then everything you you
saw gay people lesbians and everything
else um but then that it became this
other thing that we're seeing I started
seeing a fair number of male to female
transgender in the psychiatric hospital
as where as where I encountered them a
lot um
and it was an interesting group I was
you know perfectly accepted I didn't sit
in judgment or mistreat my patience any
way and and I and and then I remember
when my kids went to college so it have
been around 2011 is when boom it just
all of a sudden was everywhere this
Theory Theory and I I you know Jordan
Peterson talks about this that that this
whole Reliance on theory is ideology
right and he sees it as coming out of
this poststructuralism and the fact that
post structuralist took hold in Academia
in this country and therefore the truth
has no meaning right that's sort of one
of the post structuralist principles
it's just you know who truth and you
know it's so funny the I've heard a
couple french philosophers talk about
poststructuralism and and their thing is
like I cannot believe the US
philosophers or the US academics are so
interested in these guys from 75 years
ago 100 years ago that we cast out in
the 1960s or 70s they're just useless
and they were wrong that's the other
thing guys like Michelle
Fuko just meas demonstrably incorrect In
what he was saying and the rest of them
just poisonous in terms of saying this
is such thing is truth I was talking to
Bill Mah the other day and I said you he
went to Cornell I went Amber and I said
you know we we were taught to ascend to
an approximation of the truth to
struggle to try to get to the truth and
I said I see it in you I know that's
your training and he sort of reflected
back that yeah we kind of have that ha
together and it doesn't really exist
that much anymore it's hard to find it
yeah it's funny my audience because I
talk about Bill a lot obviously and my
audience is always like Dave but he's
always ends up voting the wrong way and
supporting all the wrong people but I'm
like but the quest is there yeah and I
can't you know someone gets to the wrong
conclusion I can play with that I can
work with that I can be friends with
that I can't be friends with the lunacy
that wants to destroy everything that's
a fundamental difference right no you
would have do you know Bill yeah yeah
you guys I would think you right have
you been on you obviously didn't watch
real time about two months ago Dave ruin
they said it was the best episode in 20
years and and they and you guys get all
got on together we were good I think you
to do Club random that you two together
be very so I did Club random about about
a year and a half ago maybe two years
now I didn't see and uh I told him that
uh I was going to New York the next day
to ring the bell for rumble so I was
like I can't really I don't want to
drink I definitely can't Mo because I
have to get on a flight I also don't
I've never done that on camera and I was
just like I don't want do any of that
then the night goes there's some tequila
he's you know he's like the guy smoke
weed like like the glaucoma patients
would be jealous and then I I left there
I was like out of my mind and I had to
get on a red eye and now I'm admitting
that to you it feels wrong to me it's
all right I I I drink around Bill too
it's it's okay wait what was the point
of all of that so okay so you have all
post post structuralism lack of theory
all this Reliance on Theory ideology
takes hold and it it reached some
critical mass around 2010 I think and
that's when it's kind of so do you
connect all that to the craziness of our
politics too that then people have just
sort of injected Politics as if politics
is going to give them meaning everything
else has been kind of blown apart and
ripped apart I think again you're ask me
to speculate it's all high degree of
speculation these are just thoughts I
have but I think part of that is yes
this sort of Drift from reality into
Theory and that there is such a
spiritual vacuum both spiritual from a
sense of some higher power or purpose
and interpersonal emptiness we're not
connected the way we should and they
have the new religion has been covid or
politics or something or anti-trump or
something it's it's it this is what's
Connecting People is these these extreme
experiences politically and socially do
do you think there's a weird this is
sort of what I was thinking with
disantis all along not not to get so
into the granular part of politics but
sort of sticking with what we're doing
that I kept thinking at the beginning
especially that people would were so
angry over Co so finally understood what
Freedom was finally understood all of
this stuff saw the migration pattern
that all of the stuff that people people
finally were going to be like all right
I want a serious leader who's decent and
competent blah blah blah and and that's
exactly what he gave them but what
I yeah that's what he gave them but what
I subsequently realize maybe at a
national level is that people really
just want the show they want the bread
in the circus in a way I don't say that
it's someone that I don't have Trump
derangement syndrome and I voted for him
last time and I'm most likely voting for
him this time but but that in a weird
way he's he's giving them something that
clearly has nothing to do with politics
it's just he's giving them something
that they just kind of want inside
rather than waking up every day and
being like wait there's no show I'm
gonna have to just go about my life
something I hate to think of it as show
I I think of it more as some sort of
high school popularity fair enough that
kind of thing and like Nikki Haley I
like her but you know it's like what
right no one's discussing what she
represents what she want to do what has
she done she ambassad to the UN right
some so and you never hear that
discussion it's all just she's being
funded by whomever so yeah that is
Gravely Gravely concerning that we are
so primitive in how we approach and then
what the the path is to those position
seems very nefarious it it just doesn't
feel like how it was supposed to be
doesn't it what what would it look like
to if we started repairing some of this
stuff I mean it from where we started
with like mental health and we Ed
repairing some of our institutions and
the media like do you think like we
actually could do it I'm starting to
just come around to like oh it really
can't be done but we'll just have
pockets of places either online or in
reality perhaps again this state that
like yeah it'll work and then and then
for large swats of formerly free sane
people they're just going to live in
like the desolation of of craziness yeah
I I I hope you're wrong um but Adam Cora
who I was here in Florida present a
podcasting award to him he didn't show
up who didn't show up to somehow that
seems very unfair you guys have worked
together for decades you're giving him
an award that he doesn't I he sent a
video could didn't play didn't work but
he said a
video uh but anyway he gave us an excuse
come see you so that's that's really
what we sort of leaned into we were like
a we'll go to South Florida everyone's
happy and we get to see Dave um he keeps
saying that it's going to be safe spaces
and octagons that the he sort of
conceives of it that way it's going to
be more m more male more aggressive more
extreme activities of various types and
more safety and more lockdowns and more
uh safety Uber Alis this idea of safety
Uber Alis is the most one of the more
toxic ideas right now the fact that that
we destroyed the world we shut the world
down to to have safety as the only
priority the one and only priority not
not any consideration no everything else
has to go over here and safety Uber Alis
that's it that that again back to Jesus
if Jesus was concerned with safety Uber
Alis would have turned out quite
different quite different it is not a
way to lead a good life I'm not saying
you should be heedless but I'm saying
you put safety as the one and only
priority in your life that is back to
Safe space as an octagon I slightly
butcher it but those who give up uh
liberty for safety deserve neither I
mean that's that's kind of the point
yeah I I had not heard that quote is
that Thomas Jefferson yeah it sounds
like Jefferson and uh I the we have got
to get back to some of these common
roots and and these people were very
wise they were very uh the way they put
this together I think one of our great
protections is the 50 states as much as
they frustrate me and I I think that is
the maybe the one thing that will get us
through this I believe we will we will
come to some sort of
a I just remember how quickly the 80s
hit do you remember do you remember that
I mean I was born in 76 so I don't
remember how they so let me remember
Empire Strikes Back came out well what
happened let me just tell you this cuz I
cuz somebody asked you the other day did
I have any kind of you know aha moment
and it oh red M Michael mice asked me
this what was a red red pill M red M and
I said well I remember this one thing
70s sucked they were horrible especially
if you were an adolescent it really they
blew and I remember hey what about
discos and you were you were I was in
college and stuff and I as it they they
were people that had fun but they they
blew for the most part and and you know
just look at the architecture and the
and the clothing it's that's all you got
they tore down Penn Station because it
was old you know come on that's the kind
of stuff was going on in the 70s like
crazy and uh and I and I remember go I I
would get the Boston Globe every day I
was in Massachusetts going to school and
uh I remember going out there one
morning and seeing this helicopter
debris strewn all over the desert it was
an botched attempt at saving the Iranian
hostages and and it just everyone just
went oh my God we suck this country's
done we're over that's it get used to it
everybody we it's it's just done the
economy sucks there are no jobs do the
best you can but this country is G
something else going to happen here and
uh so I go to medical school and I'm
about three months into medical school
and I remember I went to a house party
which had never seen anything like that
for first of all I mean there really
anything was like that uh and there were
a lot of people there and I just
remember all of a sudden dvo whip it
came
on and 100 of the people stood up and
started stancing and celebrating and I
thought this is this is totally
different than two months ago this is
Joy this is people are happy again
something has changed I just remember
that moment now I don't know you know
that you can put it into some the
economy still sucked that we had an 18%
you know rates and things were not good
and and I don't even think Reagan was in
office yet was he remember just in
office so okay and Justin off sudden and
uh I guess he had just been shot what
just had happened and so that was kind
of a weird interesting time um but but
joy and happiness and and enthusiasm and
engagement just came out of nowhere so
I'm putting that's the hopeful part for
you that is for me the hope that
experience gives a hope I'll tell you
I've been I said it on the show the last
couple days I think something about this
border thing is so obviously wrong and
and now more and more people are seeing
it so that it's finally bubbling up to
the main that it might to me seem like
the one that could actually break people
out of the malaise like it's just not
just the Mala but the the the whole
thing yeah the the silos but same thing
because gender was too confusing for
people and it's too weird it's sexual
you don't want to talk about it it's
just like it can't be discussed over the
dinner table there's something about
watching an invasion of thousands of
people that people are like okay okay
well there's watching The Invasion and
then people in the town that are being
invaded going we want to protect
ourselves and the federal government
says you can't yeah but this this is
very dicey stuff I I don't really
understand I was going to look it up
before I came in here with you maybe
you've read it but I don't understand
the little article in the Constitution
they're relying on to to to do this
because it seems to me it's kind of a
secession argument of sorts which
doesn't really
exist I heard we played a video on my
show this morning about Kevin stit who's
the Governor from Oklahoma going into
the Constitutional legality of it I mean
without getting too far in the Weeds on
it in essence the States created the
Federal Government yes and the the
federal government did not create the
states and when when the federal
government is in what is a what seems to
me at least and this is where they're
going to battle it out and further lack
of alignment well when you're in
complete dereliction of your duty the
states are allowed to protect themselves
and that's that's sort of what the
argument is which I'm in line with that
argument OB completely but I I mean
people just forget what the Constitution
it the primary purpose form a more
perfect union amongst the states the
states are the primary units and if the
states are being destroyed by the
federal government the states I mean but
this is what the secession argument was
it's just that we had there is no
there's no thing called secession
seceding because this is a a contract of
equals and so both sides have to
dissolve it or nobody dissolves it well
the inherent problem ultimately would be
that the red States I think would leave
and be quite happy about it and blue
States will never let them leave that
would be the kind of fundamental
difference how about this because I know
you have to get on a plane and go back
to California yes I do there's about uh
I'd say 10 new construction homes within
20 blocks it's here all within what all
within what I would suspect are the Dr
Drew budget I think you should take a
little drive around we did drive around
look this stuff getting here we we had
like weird uh FL Florida Envy uh well
then I've done my job and how many times
have I said that to you right I mean you
must get tired of me saying it to you
just like either it's very rewarding
come in here or don't no it's it's very
rewarding people say it to me everywhere
I brought more people into Florida
voting the right way of course than than
anyone so that's it'll be on my epit one
I I think the I think we not stop we got
to stop worrying about voting the right
way and just it's I think Bill said this
Bill said it's sanity never since sanity
we just got to get everybody sane and
lined up and and do take a good look at
revolutionary France everybody because
it it things can go really bad really
fast same thing with understand your
Civil War history understand the
American experiment what we were
intending with it the great thoughts you
have a responsibility to do that do you
really do on that note let's go into my
house and you can let me know if I'm
raising these kids right I can't wait
well Susan will at least if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell